fusion as an energy source is very
attractive it would be a carbon-free
energy source that could power mankind
forever the challenges is making fusion
work
at the National Ignition facility what
we're trying to do is overcome a natural
barrier that nature has set up for atoms
to fuse together
the idea behind fusion is the two atoms
that you try to put together those cores
have the same charge and they repel one
another just like the two parts of a
magnet 10 to repel each other one of our
main goals is to achieve thermonuclear
fusion to start a fusion fire in the
laboratory like the process that's going
on in the sun in order to create those
conditions on earth we have to
concentrate a tremendous amount of
energy in a very tiny volume and so we
built the world's biggest laser so this
facility is the size of three football
fields
it's filled with lasers and we
concentrate all those lasers into a tiny
target you know about the size of tip of
your pinky
so this is an if target where this is
the thing we put at the center of the
chamber in order to do an experiment and
all hundred and ninety two beams hit
this target so 96 beams coming from the
top 96 beams come in from the bottom and
all that energy ends up in this little
tiny target in order to start the fusion
reaction
if we do that in just the right way we
have calculations that say we should be
able to get more energy out then we put
into this implosion in light of fusion
fire that could actually power power
plants and put energy on the grid so
where we are today on the national
mission facility with regard to ignition
is we're creating a lot of fusion events
we take atoms and we force them together
and we see the energy released its kind
of like a sparking match being applied
to a bonfire you haven't yet caught the
fuel on fire in such a way that the
whole thing burns which are getting are
isolated events happening within the
bonfire stack so we see the beginnings
of the sparks but we're not there yet
with the bonfire so we were successful
in showing fusion is feasible from my
point of view would be a defining moment
much like the demonstration flight with
the Wright brothers plane in a similar
way if we get ignition on if we now
harness the same processes that power
the Sun so we will have the opportunity
before us to move from the very first
beginnings of Fire where we hid stones
together to make sparks to harnessing
the power of the Sun that's an exciting
possibility for human coming
[Music]